>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Welcome to
the Africa Middle East division.
And I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the division.
And as many of you already
know this division is made
up of three sections.
The Neary section, which is the
biggest section and it's headed
by Joan Weeks who just left to
see the investors coming up.
And the African section,
and the [inaudible] section.
Together we serve,
preserve, acquire materials
from 78 different countries in
the Middle East, Central Asia,
the Caucasus, and the
entire continent of Africa.
And our ambassador has arrived.
So hello. Hi Ambassador.
>> Rana F. Nejem: Hi, how are you?
>> Sit down.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Okay.
Okay. Please have a seat.
Yeah. That's it.
Yeah. Please, please have a seat.
Okay. Welcome, welcome, welcome.
We just now, just now and I was
saying something about our division
and our [inaudible] division
is made up of three sections,
and the Neary section is the
largest in terms of staff.
We also serve materials, as I
was saying from the Middle East,
Central Asia, the Caucasus, and
the entire continent of Africa,
as well as [inaudible]
materials from the entire world.
We're very active developing
collections, serving our patrons
in this reading room,
responding to queries
through our Oscar librarian system.
Briefing visitors coming from
all the countries of our regions.
In fact, John just had
a group of visitors
from Kyrgyzstan this morning
organizing programs, symposia,
displays, exhibits,
workshops, and so on.
And we also invite scholars
and experts who have research
and done work in our areas
of responsibility to share
with us their insights
and their findings,
so that all of us attending
these programs
and participating leave
enriched with new information
and a better understanding
of the cultures
and societies whose
publications we collect and serve.
A case in point of course is
our speaker today, Rana Nejem,
who will be talking
about her new book,
When in the Arab World an
Insider's Guide to Living
and Working With Arab Culture.
And she will be introduced by Arab
world's specialist, Nawal Kawar.
But before we start, I just
want to say how delighted I am
that among us today is Ambassador
Dina Kawar, who I was very familiar
with on television and
many of you would be to,
who was appointed Ambassador
Extraordinary and Plenipotentiary
of the Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan
to the United States in June 2016.
She served as the permanent
representative of Jordan
to the United Nations from
August 2014 through June 2016.
She has led the Jordanian delegation
during Jordan's non-permanent
membership of the United Nations
Security Council from 2014 to 2015,
and became the first Arab woman
to ever preside over the council.
In February 2016 she was
appointed by the president
of the General Assembly
as a co-facilitator
for the high level meeting of the
plenary of the General Assembly
on the large movement of refugees
and migrants from the Near East
and Africa, an issue which is
very close to my own heart.
But now to introduce Rana Nejem is
Arab word specialist Nawal Kawar.
And yes they are related.
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank you Mary-Jane.
Rana Nejem, we are
really very pleased
to have our guest speaker all
the way from Amman Jordan.
Author, social and
cultural intelligence coach,
Rana Nejem started out her career
as a broadcast journalist
with Jordan Television.
After working with CNN during
the first Gulf War she moved
to the Royal Hashemite Court where
she was responsible for his majesty,
the late King Hussein International
Media Department for two years.
Rana then moved into the
field of communications
and public relations
leading the public diplomacy
and communications work
of the British Embassy
in Amman for 18 years.
Throughout her career, whether
it was formulated communication
strategies, advising
diplomats and business people
on cross cultural communications,
conducting interviews with heads
of state or making arrangements
for royal visits and VIP events,
intercultural intelligence
and business protocol were always
an essential part of her work.
Rana learned firsthand from
top professionals in the field,
and put it all into practice
throughout her career.
Rana founded her own company in
2013 called Yarnu, Y-A-R-N-U,
an Arabic word meaning
to look towards to aspire
to with calm and serenity.
Yarnu helps people to distinguish
themselves by raising their social
and cultural intelligence
enabling them to float with ease
and confidence from one
situation to the other.
Yarnu has since been
coaching, training,
and advising business executives,
diplomats, and officers,
refined their professional
profile, increase the impact
of their personal presence,
and raise their intercultural
intelligence.
In other words, sensitivity
to the Arab culture.
She has also been helping
organizations build
and strengthen the foundation
of their corporate culture.
Her first book, When in the Arab
World, An Insider's Guide to Living
and Working With Arab
Culture was published
in the United Kingdom on May 2016.
She is regularly invited
to speak on the subject
of cross cultural communications.
Rana carries a master's degree
in international communications
and negotiations from the Fletcher
School of Law and Diplomacy,
and is certified as an
international etiquette consultant
by the International Etiquette
and Protocol Academy in London.
Rana was also trained by the
Protocol School of Washington
in international protocol
management, and is a trained coach
in intercultural intelligence.
Please help me welcome Rana Nejem.
[ Applause ]
>> Rana Nejem: Thank you so much,
and thank you for being so patient
and for waiting here with us.
When I first started working --
actually during my
last couple of years,
few years at the British Embassy
in Amman my sixth British
ambassador I served with walked
into my office one day and it was
just two weeks after he had arrived
to Jordan to take up his post there.
And he announced to me, "Well Rana,
I have just been asked
to take part in Hajaha.
Can you please tell me
what this is all about?
I've already committed."
Now of course he had no idea
what he was getting himself into.
As when there was a British
national, a British gentleman
who was living and working in Jordan
fell in love with a Jordanian girl
who comes from a quite a big tribal
family there, and they wanted to ask
for her hand in marriage.
And the British man didn't
have any of his family there.
So he asked the ambassador
to sit in for that,
and to be part of his Jaha.
Just to give you a bit of an
idea of how daunting this was.
This is what it looks like where the
elders and the most important people
in the groom's family get
together, and they meet the elders
and the most important people of the
bride's family, and then they ask
for their hand in marriage.
And it's something as formal
as this, and as big as this.
Now of course all of his diplomatic
training did not prepare him
for Ajaha, and so we
worked together.
He was well-prepared on
what he needed to do,
how he needed to greet people, how
he had to handle the cup of coffee
that was going to be
presented to him.
And at the end of it
he actually ended
up really enjoying the experience.
But the most important thing
is that this set the tone
for the rest of his stay in Jordan.
When he was seen to be doing the
correct thing and had just arrived,
it really set the tone and
made the rest of his stay
in the country so much easier.
Now the world does seem
to be getting smaller.
The media and communications and
through the whole technology seems
to be making the world a smaller
place, and seems to be unifying
in unifying us in many ways.
Still culture will never disappear.
On the contrary, the more
open the world becomes,
the more important culture becomes.
A recent Harvard study
quoted that up to 40%
of international business
ends up in failure and 70%
of those reasons is due to
cultural misunderstandings.
So that is why in this time and
age being culturally intelligent,
being culturally aware is a crucial
skill that's no longer a luxury.
So a lot of culturalists and
sociologists have likened culture
to either an iceberg or a
hippopotamus underwater.
Eighty percent of its
mass is hidden,
it's covered underneath the water,
and culture is exactly like that.
It's in that hidden part lies
all the foundations, the values,
the beliefs, that drive our
behavior, that make us see the world
in a certain way and to determine
what is appropriate, what is not,
what is acceptable, and what is not.
And it is in that part
where culture lies.
So what does that mean to us?
The reality of the matter is
that there is no impartial ground
from which to interpret reality.
The fact is we see the world
as we are, not as it is.
Our beliefs our values all of those
things that we carry on the inside
and that are affected by our culture
determine how we see the world,
how we view what is
right, what is wrong,
what is appropriate,
and what is not.
So we think we use the same words.
We think they're universal concepts.
They mean the same thing.
What else could they mean?
Words like.
I trust you.
That's pretty clear.
What else could it mean?
But if I was from a
specific culture,
I trust you means I trust
you will do the right thing.
If I was from another culture,
I trust you means I trust you
will do the honorable thing.
And honorable and [inaudible]
are completely different.
And if I was from another culture,
I trust you could mean I
trust you will protect me.
So we say, I trusted
you but you betrayed me.
What do you mean I betrayed you?
I did the right thing.
Yes, but you didn't protect me.
And that's where clashes happen.
So we move to a new culture.
It might be through work.
It might be even just
a new organization
within the same country
where you live.
And we do things just the way
that we have always been used
to doing it, because we think
that's the only way to do it.
But then we realize that the
rules of the game are different.
Things are different.
And that is what we
call cultural shock,
and that should never
be underestimated.
Cultural shock is when
your expectations
of how things should be clash
with the reality that you face,
and things as simple as
just opening the window,
you're used to seeing
greenery all the time
and then suddenly you're
in a different country.
You open the window and you
see just desert and sand,
or people that look different than
you or the food or the weather.
Never underestimate how
difficult that can be,
and what kind of stress
that can cause.
It can cause a lot of stress.
It can cause people
to actually go even
into the victim mentality
of I'm well, I'm fine.
I'm not the problem.
It's those stupid locals.
If only they did things that
they were supposed to do.
Or it's that crooked system.
If only they did things the way
that it's supposed to happen,
then everything will be fine.
I'm all right.
It can cause too a lot of
tension in the workplace.
It can cause too a lot of problems
at home, and it can actually lead
to a lot of substance abuse as well.
So even if you are the what
we call cultural learner,
an open minded person
and you have a lot
of other experiences
outside your own culture,
still prepare yourself well
before you work or move
to any other culture, and
take care of yourselves.
Don't underestimate the effect
that that will have on you.
But moving to a new culture doesn't
mean that I have to shed my skin.
It doesn't mean that I have
to forget about my own values,
forget about my own beliefs,
and go native, as they say.
No. It just means adjusting
the externals,
just adjusting the behavior.
But I keep true to my own DNA, to
my own beliefs, and own values.
And cultural intelligence
is the ability
to first look take an
honest look inside myself
to understand my own beliefs,
my own cultural values.
The reason how I see the glasses
through which I see the
world and judge the world.
Only then am I able to
anticipate other people's behavior.
Correctly interpret that behavior,
and then adjust my own behavior
to match the culturally
motivated behavior of others.
And that is being culturally
intelligent.
Now, a lot of researchers have
come up with many theories,
and tools that are meant to help
us understand how culture affects
our behavior.
These are old guidelines
that are meant
to just help us better understand
how culture affects our behavior.
But the most important thing we
need to always keep in mind is
that we never deal with
cultures, we deal with people.
And each individual has
their own self culture.
And by self culture I mean so,
for example, I'm Jordanian,
but I'm far from a
typical Jordanian.
My mother is Jordanian.
My father is Palestinian.
They brought me up in a certain way.
I grew up in Kuwait.
I picked up a lot of that culture.
I studied in the US for a while.
I picked up some of that culture.
I worked with the British
for a while.
I picked up a lot of their culture.
So I have created my own
self culture in the end.
So we need to remember always
that we deal with people,
and each person needs to be treated
and respected as an individual.
But one of the many
theories and tools
that were used was one called
the three colors of worldview,
which was first brought by Roland
Wooler, who did a lot of research
on the Bedouins and then another
organization called Knowledge Works
that are set up in Dubai and the
Netherlands took up that research
and expanded it and applied
it on the business world.
And this is the tool that I use as a
basis in my research and in my book.
So let's move on to
When in the Arab World.
Start from the basics.
I say the Arab world, but of course
the Arab world is not one big lump.
It's made up of 22
independent countries.
Each country has its own
specific unique culture,
unique history, and
unique traditions.
Still having said that, there
is a thread of commonalities
that ties us all together, and that
is based in the Islamic religion
and in the Bedouin culture.
Knowing of course that not
all of the Arab countries come
from the Bedouin culture, but there
is this thread of commonalities
that can justify the kind of
generalities that I make in the book
and that I will make today.
But again these are the core,
the values, the main motivators
of behavior that can
explain as a guideline
of what motivates our
behavior in the Arab culture.
Basics again, before
we move any further.
Arab and Muslim are
not the same thing.
The media here unfortunately
uses the term
to interchangeably to
mean the same thing.
They're not.
Even though the majority of
the Arab population is Muslim,
not all Arabs are Muslim.
Depending on which source you
use up to around 13 percent,
13 or 14 percent are Christians.
And Christianity started
from the Arab world.
It did not come with the Crusades.
So actually Jesus Christ
was born here.
And so, not all Arabs are Muslim,
and not all Muslims are Arabs.
Actually the majority of
the Muslim populations
in the world are is
not the Arab world.
It's in Asia.
So be careful not to use those two
terms as the to mean the same thing.
If we are looking at the
main motivator of behavior,
the centrality of honor,
faith, saving face
and pride cannot be
overestimated in the Arab culture.
It is central to understanding
how we do everything,
and the reasons why
we do everything.
The main motivator of behavior
in the Arab culture is basically
to safeguard my honor
and avoid shame.
If you were to walk away with just
one thing today if you understand
that the centrality of that
it will help you ease your way
around dealing with so many
aspects of the Arab culture.
But who determines whether
I have been honorable
or if I have done anything of shame?
Is it the legal system?
No. It's the people.
It's my community.
It's the people around me,
and therefore it makes
absolute sense why we put
such weight on reputation.
The public perception of how
people see us, and what people say
about us is very, very important,
because again it reflects
on our honor.
And honor here also means might
mean something completely different
from what may be an American
person might conceive as honor.
Remember in these cultures this
is a community based culture.
This is where the group,
the community is far more
important than the individual.
And here I don't only
represent myself,
I represent everyone
else in the community.
Just look at the way
that we write our names.
So our names as written
so my first name.
My name Rena, followed
by my father's name,
followed by his father's name,
followed by the family name,
and then the tribal name,
if I belong to a tribe.
So just by looking at a person's
name you can actually tell
where exactly they
fit into that society.
You can tell which part of
the country they come from.
You can tell if it's a
Christian or a Muslim family,
and in many cases you can even tell
their political affiliation just
by a name.
So that's why someone from the Arab
world we might think it's a bit odd
that you have a middle
name that your parents pick
out for absolutely no reason.
For us it tells a whole story
of where you sit in that --
where your position
is in that culture.
Saving face becomes a very, very
important concept that you have
to keep in mind, especially
if you're doing any
kind of negotiations.
If you're giving any
kind of feedback.
Again, the main motivator is to
avoid shaming, and to maintain
that honor, because I don't
just bring honor to my --
I don't just bring shame to
myself, I bring that to everyone
that I represent, everyone
that I hold the name of.
Naturally in an honor based culture,
the family becomes the
most important thing.
Loyalty to the family
comes above all else.
And by family here, I mean
the very extended family.
So we're looking at uncles,
cousins, second cousins,
that whole big family,
extended family is a network
of support for every individual.
They are the patriarch is
the head of the family.
Elders are revered.
They take members of the same
family look out for each other.
Our support for each other in
the good times and the bad times,
but it's also a double edged sword.
Their support for each other,
but they also hold
each other accountable.
And that's why maybe an
uncle might have a say
in who I decide to get married to.
But at the other end of the
spectrum, they are always there.
They're supporting each
other through thick and thin.
And that's why you find rarely,
rarely find any homeless people
across the Arab world, because
they're always taken care of,
taken in by some member
of their family somewhere.
And you saw that what happened
exactly during the Syrian crisis
in the very, very beginning.
All of the Syrian refugees that
came across were actually absorbed
by family members in Jordan, and
then until a few months later
when all of the family's
homes were completely full,
then we found that we had --
there were too many people
and the refugees camp
started to be set up.
But then the resulting
social structure is
that children stay
living with their families
until they get married
themselves, and then they move
out to set up their own families.
The end in many cases in
many different cultures,
and many different
countries you will find
that the young man will get
married and maybe bring his wife
and children in the
family home as well.
They all take care of each other.
When the wife, when the lady goes up
to work the children are left looked
after either by her own mother
or by her mother in law.
Friday which is the main day
weekend day is spent with lunch,
and with the extended family, and
that's the most important thing.
Family businesses are
most actually businesses
across the Arab world
are family owned.
And so if you end up working with
a family business, be very careful.
Criticism of any family member,
even though it might be
well-deserved is not a
good suggestion.
So stay away from that.
The difference here, the generation
gap, between the older generation
and the younger generation,
what's called Generation X
and Generation Y, and I think there
are other letters now I think is
more pronounced in the Arab
culture than in any other culture.
The gap there is I
think maybe even wider.
The younger generation now
they are 60% of the population
across the Arab world
is under the age of 25.
That makes it the most
youthful area of the world.
Very young.
And this younger generation
is changing a lot of things.
They are much more outward looking.
They are much more connected
to the rest of the world.
They're educated in the
best universities in Europe,
and in the US., and they
want to change things a lot.
But what you find now
that's happening is
that although they may not add so
much as much weigh and value to the
to the traditions as
their fathers did.
Still they are holding on
to the core cultural values,
and they're finding very creative
ways of getting to what they want,
but within their culture,
within their communities.
And you will see, keep seeing
those changes happening now.
The issue of women in Arab
culture I think is one
that is the most misrepresented
aspect
of the Arab culture probably Arab
women across the board have broken
so many cultural taboos, have
achieved so much across the board
in the fields of politics,
in medicine,
in business, and in everywhere.
I'm not going to go
into the full details
of how much women have
achieved and all of that issue.
But still the Arab, the structure
of the Arab society is
a patriarchal society.
The male dominance is very much
ingrained in the Arab culture,
and many women still
remain under a sort
of a little bit subversive
socially only
to the male members of their family.
So the main decisions are
made by either the father
or the husband or the brother.
But still do not jump
to conclusions here.
This is one area of the culture
I think in across the board
where it's very easy to
fall into stereotypes,
and to make judgments
based on appearances.
They tell you it looks like a
duck, it quacks like a duck,
it walks like a duck, and then
therefore it must be a duck.
Probably anywhere except here.
It's probably not a duck.
You look at this lady
and you think, right.
We see a woman wearing
the hijab covered up
and we think she's probably
oppressed, she's probably ignorant,
she has no idea about her
rights and gender equality,
and I'm going to come here
and tell her about her rights
and gender equality, and women's
issues and I will free her
from the tyranny of the veil.
Think again.
This woman is a Saudi woman.
Her name is Nalla Yan..
She actually owns and
runs the largest financial
and industrial corporation
in the region.
This is another lady.
She's a minister of
international cooperation in Egypt,
and another also a minister in
a very dominated liberal Qassemi
and the UAE, very male
dominated culture,
but yet she is the minister,
was the minister of economy
and now has several
portfolios as well.
A group of Jordanian
women MPs as well.
The issue of gender equality
and women's rights is
something that's really fraught
with so many cultural minefields.
That whole concept of
the freedom to choose,
and personal freedom is a
very American way of thinking.
Other cultures including the Arab
culture, put a lot more weight
on our position in the
end role in the society.
A lot more, that has a lot more
meaning than personal freedom,
and even freedom the
end of the whole concept
of freedom means something
completely different
in different cultures.
So be aware when not
to jump to conclusions
on what other women need based on
your own cultural views and values.
And this is just one picture
that you don't often see
coming out of the Arab culture.
This is a very famous
Lebanese singer.
Her name is Nancy Hallström.
So one other thing that
differs from one culture
to the other is the how we see
this concept of faith and faith.
In some cultures, like the American
culture here, we believe here
or it's maybe just the
perception that you are in control
of your destiny, that
you predict the weather.
You work hard.
It's the cause and effect mentality.
The [inaudible] thinking,
cause and effect.
You predict the weather.
I am the master of my ship.
I control my destiny.
It's a belief or perhaps
it's just a perception.
In other cultures, again it's a
belief or perhaps a perception
that we don't actually have that
much control over circumstances
or anything that happens around us.
If something happens,
whether it's good or bad,
it was something outside
of my hands left
up to a power far greater
than myself.
Call it the universe.
Call it God.
Call it Allah.
Call it luck.
How you look at it, different,
so someone from the American
culture might think, hmm,
that's very passive and lazy.
And someone from the Arab culture
would look at the American belief,
and think that's pretty arrogant.
I can work.
I will do all I can do, but
then I get to a certain point
and then things are out of my hands.
The belief in we have a term
in Arabic, Kadiatu cadet,
which is faith and God's
will, literally translated.
Means that I can do
everything I can.
I will work, do my best, but then
whatever is left is out of my hands.
If you ask any American, a group
of American people you'd say,
so how many of you have already
booked a holiday, a flight,
and booked your hotels
and know exactly
where you're going next
summer for holiday?
Show of hands.
Have you? No, okay.
We've got some there.
[laughs] It's very accepted.
It's the norm that you plan ahead
at least six, seven, eight months,
maybe a year ahead of time.
For someone coming from the Arab
culture, that's completely bizarre.
Because I don't know if I'm going
to be alive six months from now,
let alone if I actually am
going to feel like going
to that particular vacation.
I don't know who in my family
is going to get married,
who's going to have a baby.
I don't know if there's
going to be a war next door.
So we don't plan.
Everything's left to
the last minute.
And that affects every
aspect of our life.
Why we've had business consultants
who come to the Arab world and try
to do financial forecasting.
And business plans, five
year advance business plans.
It's tough.
The belief is that
we are tempting fate.
And of course if you
come to anywhere
in the Arab world what's the
first word that you will hear?
Inshallah.
[laughs] Inshallah.
And Inshallah literally
means God willing.
But when I was doing research
for the book I discovered
that we didn't invent
that concept actually.
There is a Latin term that
the Brits used in the 1900s,
when they signed their name to any
letters, they used the Latin term,
deo volente, which
literally means God willing.
God willing, if God permits,
whatever I said I will
do, I will do.
So we didn't invent that Inshallah.
But again, it is that
concept and belief
in that things are out of my hand.
I don't have absolute control over
my circumstances and what happens.
Religion is also a very
integral part of everyday life.
The word "Islam," in Arabic means
the willing submission to God.
And that seeps through a lot of
things that we do in business,
and politics across the board.
And you will find it that it
actually has nothing to do
with the level of education.
It has nothing to do even with,
you know, Christians Muslims,
you find that some of these
beliefs and values and traditions
and the way we do things get mixed
up, and are completely intertwined,
and affect how everything is done.
So if we look at now the style of
communications, if we understand
that the main motivator of
behavior is to safeguard my honor
and avoid shame, then it makes sense
that we prefer the indirect
style of communications.
In the western culture
it's very direct.
It's I say what I mean
and I mean what I say.
Very direct, straight
to the point, clear.
In Arab culture I have a lot of
other things going on in my mind
that I want to juggle while I'm
trying to get the message across.
I want to make sure I save my face.
I want to make sure
I save your face.
I want to make sure I'm honoring us.
And I want to make sure I
safeguard that relationship.
There's so many things that
I'm thinking about other
than just getting that
message across.
And this is one area that
causes a lot of stress
and miscommunications
among different cultures.
So let me tell you an example.
So if I have my boss is John, and
I want to tell John something.
And of course we never
want to upset the boss.
So I think about if
I want to tell John
that I'm not quite
sure how he's going
to take it, who is close to John?
Okay. So maybe Eudunda might be.
So I will go talk to Eudunda and
I'll tell her, Linda I really want
to tell John this, but I'm not quite
sure how he's going to take it.
So she would think a bit and
think, don't worry about it.
I'll see. I'll take care of it.
She will then think
and go tell him Hamid.
And we'll tell Hamid this is
what we want to tell John.
What do you think about that?
And then Hamid will go tell John.
Message delivered.
No confrontation.
No problem.
Now John would then of course
have a nervous breakdown,
because he would be very
offended and would think first,
why are you going behind my back?
And second, why are you involving
people that don't need to know
about this issue in the first place?
But if you understand the
reason why this is happening,
and it's about avoiding
confrontation,
trying to get that message across.
One, saving face, saving
honor, saving the relationship.
It gets very complicated, but
there is this is how you can
when you understand why it happens,
then it might lessen the offense
taken or the reaction taken.
Having said that, of course,
there are certain ways
that we are much more direct
than any other culture.
It's one of the stories that I use
in the book is this David he
walks, he's working in Jordan.
He gets into a taxi, and
the first question is,
"Hello, where are you from?"
He says, "From the UK."
"Oh, Manchester United.
Nice football.
Are you married?"
"Yes." "How many children?"
"No children."
"Really, why?"
"We don't have any children."
"Have you been to the doctor?"
[laughs] And of course when
David wants knows this is the --
wants to end the conversation,
he would end it with,
"It's out of my hands.
It's all in the hands of God."
And that's where the
conversation ends.
But somebody like David
who was actually very culturally
aware never got offended by that,
and he would laugh and think that
if somebody in the UK if I had
to have this conversation somewhere
in the UK, it would be horrific.
Completely out of out of order.
But then this is the difference
between what is accepted
and what is not and what
is direct and in direct.
But one of the other ways of
communicating that's very important
in Arab culture is the face
to face communications.
While it is you can actually
get a lot done over email
or just a phone call
in other cultures,
don't expect that to happen
anywhere across the Arab world.
It has to be done face to
face, and it takes time,
because everything is
about the relationship.
Relationships are more
important than anything else,
and you will find in many cases
that people will take a decision
that might be bad for
business, but that in order
to safeguard a relationship.
So while it takes a little bit of
time to build that relationship,
and it's said that two American
business people can get off
to different planes,
meet in an airport lobby,
and set up a business
together if they have a product
and a business plan
they will do that
and they walk away their different
paths, and it will be successful.
That can never happen
anywhere in the Arab world.
Everything is based
on relationships,
and building relationships
is core, but takes time.
And that is where it's
the investment
in that relationship
that's very important,
and it needs to be
done face to face.
After you've established that,
then you can take it to
emails and telephone.
But it has to be that trust and the
relationship has to start first.
One thing if I may really
more and against here,
it's that condescending attitude
that we get a lot from a lot
of foreign experts
that come our way.
Now, the region, the Arab region has
been developing at such a fast pace
that it's going incredibly fast
that it's actually outrunning,
if you like, the abilities
of a lot of its people
and the abilities of
some of its leaders.
So that's why we will
always continue to have
to need the foreign
experts and the advice
of the foreign experts,
but be careful here.
The all that used to we used
to have, the older generation
of Arabs towards the foreign
expert is diminishing fast.
And you will find that in especially
in the GCC there's the national
pride is growing more and more.
And they are replacing a
lot of the foreign experts
with the local nationals.
Be aware of this condescending
attitude
of we are here to instruct you.
Or we are here to teach
you, because we know better.
We know the right way.
Just do as we say, and we've got it.
That's one thing that a lot of
foreign experts make that mistake.
It's a very small community.
Everyone knows everyone, and
everything travels by word of mouth.
And if your reputation is that
you are in a place of trust
and respect, that will travel fast.
And you will be able
to do great business,
but otherwise that news
will travel fast as well
and you will not be able to do
much anywhere in the Arab world.
Language. Lost in Translation.
The Arabic language, just to say
that very quickly, it
comes in two parts.
The instructions were
to write this in Arabic,
and they did exactly that.
The Arabic language is in two parts.
There's the classical Arabic, and
there's the colloquial Arabic.
The classical Arabic is the same
Arab language, the same Arabic
that is spoken across
all 22 Arab countries.
It's the same Arabic that is
written in books, in newspapers,
and you will hear it read
on the television newscast
or the radio newscast.
That is the same one that's
across all of the Arab world.
And then there's the colloquial
Arabic, which is different
in each country, and each country
has its different dialect as well.
So, but you'll find that, for
example, the GCC countries,
the Gulf countries
have a similar dialect.
The Levant, Jordan,
Lebanon, Palestine,
and Syria have similar dialect.
Egypt is very distinct.
Iraq is very distinct.
And the North African countries
all have a similar dialect as well.
But each country has
separate accents.
You can tell the difference between
Kuwait, and [inaudible] and Saudi
by the accent, and the
certain words that they use.
The important thing here is if you
think that you can do a campaign
or issue a press release at
headquarters, here in the US,
and then send it out for
translation, think again.
A lot can get messed
up in the translation.
When I was working with a
British foreign office I worked
on a campaign, and in 2012
for the 2012 London Olympics there
was a fantastic campaign called The
Great Britain campaign.
A great year for Great Britain.
And everything was fashioned was
Great Britain is Great Britain.
Education is Great Britain.
Sports is Great Britain.
And I was one on the panel
that was trying to translate
that campaign into Arabic.
And if anyone speaks Arabic can
understand that this actually
when you translate it, it rings
about all the colonial past.
And actually it is
completely counter campaign.
So it's actually very,
very negative.
And we ended up choosing
at least in Jordan not
to use the Arabic translation,
because it was actually
counterproductive,
and was getting us into an area
which we were trying
to work against.
So be careful.
Just the translation will not work.
It's really advised to use the local
talent that you have in the country.
They know the nuances of the
language, and what would go,
what would work here,
and what would not.
So in closing, cultural
intelligence again starts
from an honest look
inside ourselves first.
I have to look inside myself at my
own beliefs, my own cultural values,
how I view the world, and how I
determine what's right and wrong.
And only then can I anticipate
other people's behavior.
Correctly interpret that behavior,
and adjust my own behavior
to suit the culturally
motivated behavior of others.
And remember again, we never,
we don't deal with
cultures, we deal with people.
And every person must be
respected as an individual.
Use the local talent you
have wherever you are.
Ask, you will always get an answer.
People are very friendly and open
and would love to give advice.
Don't make assumptions at all.
And don't forget to get a
copy of one in the Arab world.
[laughs]. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank you,
Rana for a wonderful speech.
Now we open the floor
for questions, please.
>> Rana F. Nejem Questions, yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> I was wondering in technical
terms what is the attitude
of society towards old
people, the season,
the experience like
at the workplace.
Are they regarded just
as revered or as regarded
as [inaudible] their wisdom
on the job [inaudible]?
>> Nawal Kawar: Repeat that.
>> Rana F. Nejem: The question
is how are older people
in the Arab culture, what's the
attitude towards older people
in the Arab culture in the
workplace in particular.
Are they revered or are
they expected to retire?
It actually it varies again.
But in general, the wisdom
of the older generation is very much
respected, and they are even the way
that you speak to an older person
is and the way that you communicate
and interact with an older person,
the way you address an older person,
there is a lot of respect when
you are actually interacting
with somebody older.
In the workplace now just
recently things are changing
as the younger generation are coming
more and more into the workplace,
and because of the
invasion of the technology
and how things are being
done are changing a lot.
There is this attitude of, and of
course with social media changing
that as well, which gave
everyone a megaphone and a size
that is quite larger than
their true size I would say,
has changed the balance
a little bit.
And undoubtedly it is
creating some sort of,
I don't know if it's tension
or how things are changing,
but in general the culture
continues to respecting the elders
and the wisdom of the Elders
is very, very important.
Thank you.
Question? Yes.
>> I'm curious about how the US
[inaudible] culturally speaking
[inaudible] better in communicating
and understanding [inaudible]
where you see trends
in how [inaudible] related
to various societies.
>> Rana F. Nejem: So the question is
about whether the American
military has been able,
have learned to be more culturally
sensitive in the Arab countries
where it's functioning,
where it's present.
It's difficult to generalize
here, but I think there were a lot
of in the past there were several
clashes or incidences that showed
that there was very little cultural
awareness and understanding.
And so what ended up happening
now is that you will find
that they are very isolated
from the rest of the culture.
So they live wherever there is
a US military base you'd find
that isolated from the
rest of the culture.
They have their own, I
don't know commiserate,
they have their own entertainment,
so that they don't actually interact
a lot with the local culture.
This differs from one
country to the other,
but I would say more
cultural sensitivity
and awareness is still needed.
And it's just because when
you don't know something,
and you make assumptions on what
you already believe is right,
you're going to do what
you think is right.
Which is the natural thing.
It's your default setting.
But that thing that's right for
you doesn't work in another place,
and that causes offense,
but you don't know
that you're causing offense.
And so I think there is still room
for a bit more cultural awareness
training, and more knowledge,
more about the nuances, the
values, the beliefs, the motivators
of behavior, rather than just giving
them a list of do's and don'ts.
Don't sit with the sole of
your foot facing somebody.
Don't do that.
Those are those are very important
things, but they don't explain why.
Does that answer your question?
Thank you.
Yes.
>> I was really fascinated by your
remarks on the men in Arab world,
and the assumptions that others make
about the [inaudible] about choice
and about being independent.
And I guess I want more insight
about this younger generation
of women in the Arab world.
How do they define feminism?
What do you think you
can share, you know,
maybe just give us some
light on that [inaudible]/
>> Rana F. Nejem: Yes.
yes. So the questions about how the
younger generation of Arab women
and how they are viewing feminism
and how they are viewing their role,
their world, their rights.
It's fascinating to see the
changes that are happening.
But the number of women actually,
and from the younger
generation who choose.
And I underline choose to wear
the hijab, which is the scarf,
which is very different from the
niqab is actually on the increase.
They are a lot more now.
But the interesting thing is that
how it is -- how you doing that.
How they're doing it
with it's into fashion.
And now you find so many new young
fashion designers who are coming
up with the most amazing designs
on the catwalk for specially
for Arab women who
want to be fashionable,
but want to be modest
at the same time.
And you find that it's
simply an item of clothing
that does not prevent them from
doing anything or being anywhere.
They go out to restaurants,
they dine.
There's sometimes there's
alcohol being served.
As long as they're not
drinking that's fine.
They are in sports.
They're in football.
They're in medicine.
They can do anything.
This is simply an item of
clothing that reflects on --
it's something that's their cultural
or religious values and beliefs
that does not prevent
them in any way
of achieving their full potential
in any field that they choose.
So we look at that item of clothing,
and we give it a lot more weight
meaning than it really needs to.
We attach so many of our
own assumptions to it.
That she's not free, she's
oppressed, she's ignorant,
but that's all of us really.
It's in the eye of the
beholder, as it said.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Everything you said
I identify with.
When you hear somebody saying
it, it's just a comedy.
It's true.
[laughs] I remember my children
who were raised then in France.
You know, in Jordan everybody
asks how many kids do you have.
What this, what that, and the
French they [inaudible] that.
They find if interfering
in private matters.
So my children was always
getting, you know, a cold shower.
Then they ask somebody
do you have kids?
It's like this is very personal.
This is very private.
And it took them a while to
realize the cultural aspect,
so they stopped doing it, you know?
>> Rana F. Nejem: Yes.
>> And it's true that there is so
many things that can be offensive,
and [inaudible] because I have
a copy you kindly sent me,
and explaining these
things [inaudible]
and everybody who's interested
and at least or even not,
just in these cultures
[inaudible] read them.
So I just wanted to tell you bravo.
>> Rana F. Nejem: Thank you.
Thank you.
It's very interesting, so the topics
of conversation there's
a whole chapter
on the topics of conversation.
So in the US, for example when
you meet somebody you chit chat,
the small talk we call.
And the small talk is
you ask about the wife.
How's the wife, how the -- you
don't do that in the Arab world.
The wife is completely private.
You never ask about the wife.
You ask about the family.
You ask about the children,
but never the wife.
And when you go visit
somebody's home,
you never take a gift that's
personal for the wife.
You take flowers, chocolate, not a
bottle of wine, unless you really,
really know that they drink, and
you've visited their house before,
but the wife is always private.
So it's interesting how.
Yes.
>> Just more like a comment.
But this is all about
[inaudible] world.
But with experience Egyptians
are not [inaudible] Egyptians.
>> Rana F. Nejem: Definitely.
Definitely.
Of course now there's -- this
is what I said in the beginning.
These are the basic values
that are the same more or less
across the Arab world,
but there are differences.
Of course life in Beirut is vastly
different from life in Riyadh.
So you will find the social
differences and within each country
if you're in the capital
city it's very different
than if you're in the rural areas.
But once you understand those basic
values, the motivators of behavior,
then you're able to
intelligently weigh your
and adjust according
to each local country.
And then you're able to really
enjoy the magic of each country.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Rana F. Nejem.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.